well we conclude our series on kids and
culture tonight with boys being boys if
you have one or more you know young
males can be a handful but when does
that become a medical issue
correspondent Ellison barber takes a
look tonight 6.1 million that's how many
US children as of 2016 have been
diagnosed with ADHD according to the CDC
and the CDC says boys adolescents ages
12 to 17 are the ones receiving most of
the ADHD diagnosis in 2014 a lengthy
article in Esquire looked at some of the
numbers they argued that many boys are
being medicated and penalized not
because they have a major issue but
because they're just being boys and boys
aren't always calm they can be rough
they're often considered to be more
aggressive than girls they can be dirty
they can be noisy Howard Glasser says
far too many are put on medication
typical boyish behavior that went beyond
curiosity to acting out that pushed
limits would be you know the red flag
and and somebody would make a call and
say your child needs an evaluation he
says the best way to help many of these
kids is not with medicine but with a
quote nurtured heart approach the same
intensity that drives people crazy that
leads people to diagnosis is actually
the very same energy that is the source
of a child's greatness dr. Bob andhave
says the ADHD numbers can be misleading
more boys are diagnosed with ADHD but
that could be because girls are often
overlooked as those boys who are
hyperactive and impulsive make a lot of
noise in the classroom and the teachers
notice whereas the girls who are more
inattentive and distractible don't make
as much noise sometimes he says medicine
is the best option for treatment depends
on the kid and it's apparent dr.
decision but dismissing the behavior is
a recipe for disaster
kids who have ADHD who grew up to be
adults who have ADHD who don't get
treatment they have a harder time
keeping jobs they're more at risk for
substance abuse they're more at risk for
major conduct issues and maybe in
criminal
gave your boys just being boys while
it's a convenient way to explain the
behavior it doesn't necessarily capture
all of these kids who may have some
serious problems
this mom noticed her son struggling in
elementary school after trying different
things Diane Dempster decided he needed
more help and medicine was part of the
help this is a real struggle this is a
challenge if you've got a kid who's
struggling in school if you've got a kid
who's struggling with attention issues
with hyperactivity it's a real challenge
of those 6.1 million diagnosed with ADHD
the CDC says roughly two-thirds take
medication Shannon
Ellison Barbara thank you very much